Adrienne's with us in Memphis Merry
Christmas Adrienne
Merry Christmas very very youth better
than I deserve how can I help found you
probably about a week ago and I
subscribed to your YouTube channel and
I'm trying to get started on cutting
down on my debt I really just don't know
where to begin I recently just bought a
house and I'll be closing on the house
and January the 5th so worst case and it
were the worst thing offering is I have
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in student loans by myself and my
husband and I both have car loans and
the house we just bought is 73 25 and I
am a veteran so I won't have to pay the
PMI but I'm also trying to figure out
should I put money down on the half or
should I just pay it with the notes the
banker that I'm using told me not to put
any down payment on the house hmm two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
during alone day are you a doctor or a
lawyer a doctor so what do you but I'm
not working currently I stay home with
my one-year-old why because I got out of
the military and when I moved back to my
home state I just really had a hard time
finding a hospital that would hire me
and I don't want to take out any more
lungs to open up a pilot pipes I'm not
even private practice minded really so
I'm trying to avoid that I mean if it
comes to there I will do this I don't
want to take any more loans but you're
gonna have to go to work immediately
immediately
I mean you intern $50,000 in debt to
become a matter I could to become an MD
you have to go earn the income to pay
that off you didn't leave yourself any
choices when you went to 150 thousand
dollars in debt you made the decision to
work didn't you okay you have to yeah I
mean what does your husband make
ninety-five
yeah and so you can make that you can
make six figures and you pay this debt
off in three years and you're going to
have to you have got to go find a job
and and you know you can make you can
make a hundred thousand a hundred fifty
thousand I don't know general I don't
know what you do what your
specialization is but you're an MD and
you you've got to go to work you don't
have a choice this idea of you staying
home with the one-year-old isn't not
even an option and I would love for you
to I'm not trying to push you into the
marketplace but you made that decision
years ago when you went $250,000 in debt
promising yourself you'd be a doctor and
promising yourself you'd use that big
income to pay off that debt right now
you got to keep that promise that's what
it comes down to because it's your
family is going to be crippled by two
otherwise financially for decades by you
being a doctor I can stay at home mom
with that MD you you I'm not saying you
have to work for 20 years but you've got
to work long enough to clean this mess
up
okay all right and immediately ready set
go
immediately how much money do y'all have
saved we have sixty thousand and a
savings there fifteen thousand a million
market okay well you need an emergency
fund and the rest of it goes on the
student loans and you take the minimum
put the minimum down on the house okay
and by the way you don't avoid PMI on a
VA loan
if you're a veteran there's a funding
fee on a VA loan and the VA loan is one
of the more expensive loans for veterans
it's not a good deal you know what I'm
going to change that I want you to talk
to your mortgage broker about maybe you
need a new mortgage broker the one I
think you have sucks because they're
giving you bad advice I think you
probably could get a lot cheaper loan on
this if you put down a good down payment
on a conventional and I want you to run
the numbers on the Fannie Mae does a
Fannie Mae loan is considerably cheaper
than a VA loan because the VA loans got
the funding fee they've got all this
other crap built into it and the
interest rates are generally 1/8 to 1/4
higher and they're just not a good deal
I think you can get a Fannie Mae
fixed-rate 15
and you may need to use some of this
money for your down payment and let's
get the house closed because you've
committed to it
I mean you've signed the contract and so
you need to go you know follow through
on your word on that and then you need
to follow through on the promise you
made to yourself was that you were gonna
be a doctor and pay off these loans so
now you're gonna be a doctor and pay off
these loans as soon as possible and and
then if you want to quit and go home you
can do whatever you want to do when you
get to where you're financially
responsible in doing so but with that
kind of income potential and that kind
of debt those two things are you have to
use that to do that I'm sorry I'm sorry
that you're in this situation but it's
the decisions you made so that that's
what I would have you do yeah let's put
a better down payment on the house do a
Fannie Mae fixed-rate 15-year avoid PMI
and avoid the VA funding fees and get a
cheaper interest rate call churchill
mortgage and have them work those
numbers for you i think they'll show you
what I'm talking about is true so and
then get that closed and then let's move
on to the next thing so good question
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh